The third episode of Game of Thrones' eighth
season wasted no time diving into the action
of the Battle of Winterfell, coming in hot
and holding nothing back.
Sure to be remembered as one of the most epic
entries in Thrones history, "The Long Night"
pitted the living against the dead, the light
against the dark, and fire against ice.
Many characters took their final breaths in
the cold Winterfell air.
Here's a look at the characters who didn't
make it, and one big winner.
The bodies start falling from the first swing
of a sword.
Even equipped with flaming weapons and steadfast
determination, the Dothraki aren't men of
myths or the enders of the Long Night.
Soon after they forge ahead into the darkness,
with Jon's direwolf Ghost charging alongside
them, the Dothraki outriders are wiped out
by the wights.
The side of the living quickly becomes overwhelmed
by the dead.
Jon and Daenerys send their dragons, Rhaegal
and Drogon, out into battle to breathe fire
onto the enemy, to little avail.
The dead aren't dying, an out-of-this-world
windstorm clouds everyone's vision, people
are dropping left and right, and the episode's
first major death comes when Lord Commander
of the Night's Watch Dolorous Edd dies via
stabbing when trying to save Samwell Tarly.
Newly knighted Brienne then orders the forces
to retreat into Winterfell's gates.
"Fall back!"
The speed at which the battle devolves into
chaos pushes Arya to send her sister Sansa
to the crypts, the so-called safest place
in Winterfell, with a dragonglass dagger.
"I don't know how to use it."
"Stick them with the pointy end."
In the catacombs, Sansa joins her former husband
Tyrion Lannister, Sam's partner Gilly, Varys,
and Missandei, plus every woman, child, and
elderly person in Winterfell.
Sansa, Tyrion, and Missandei exchange barbs
before the situation becomes no laughing matter.
As fans predicted, the corpses resting in
the Stark family crypt come back to life and
take victims down with zero difficulty or
remorse.
While dozens die screaming behind them, Sansa,
Tyrion, Gilly, Varys, and Missandei make it
out of the crypts alive, and their survival
may spell trouble moving forward.
Tyrion, Varys, and Missandei are on Daenerys'
side; they've all bent the knee and pledged
loyalty to her.
Sansa, on the other hand, hasn't warmed up
to her yet, and might never once she realizes
that Jon is the true heir to the Iron Throne.
Theon Greyjoy has done some serious repenting
since betraying House Stark at the start of
the War of the Five Kings.
Taken in as a ward and a prisoner of Ned Stark
following his own father's duplicity, Theon
grew up in Winterfell and had long been considered
a member of the Stark family.
Theon's treachery against the Starks reached
its apex when he seized Winterfell in the
second season of Game of Thrones, capturing
two farm boys and displaying their burned
bodies on the castle's walls, passing them
off as Bran and Rickon Stark.
Beneath the Weirwood tree in Winterfell's
godswood, where Bran awaits the Night King,
Bran absolves Theon of his sins.
Bran tells him that everything he's done brought
him to where he is now: home.
You are a good man."
The Night King then emerges, and Theon attempts
stab him with a spear, but it's no use.
The Night King kills Theon with a swift jab.
There's a bright side, though: at least he
died knowing Sansa, Jon, and finally Bran
forgave him.
Several more perished fighting in the Battle
of Winterfell.
Beric Dondarrion was all out of extra lives
when the wights stabbed him multiple times
while he protected Arya.
Little Lyanna Mormont, the ferocious lass
from Bear Island who insisted she take part
in the fight, dies a heroic death when she
bravely stabs a wight giant in the eye and
is subsequently crushed in its hand.
Alys Karstark falls offscreen.
She was among the people protecting Bran alongside
Theon in the godswood.
Then came Jorah Mormont, who died defending
Daenerys to the bitter end.
When a pack of wights unleash fury on Drogon,
who takes flight and abandons Dany, the Mother
of Dragons is left to fight off enemies herself
— until Jorah swoops in and protects her
from what end up being fatal blows.
Dany sheds many tears over the loyal Jorah.
As the sun begins to rise and the night slips
under the horizon, the Red Woman Melisandre
walks out of Winterfell, stepping between
two mounds of dead bodies like Moses parting
the Red Sea, and willingly ends her own life.
She removes the red-amulet-adorned necklace
that perpetually sat around her throat, continues
out into the battlefield, and leaves this
mortal coil.
In season 6, it was revealed that Melisandre
wasn't the youthful woman she appeared to
be.
She was incredibly old, and the necklace extended
her life.
With it off for too long, she was bound to
succumb to the effects of extreme old age.
Melisandre likely felt her work in Westeros
was complete, and she may have been harboring
guilt over the death of little Shireen Baratheon,
whom she helped burn at the stake in season
5.
She also kept good on two past promises.
She once shared a prediction with Varys:
"I will return, dear spider.
One last time."
"My lady…"
"I have to die in this strange country."
She also told Ser Davos at the start of the
Battle of Winterfell that she would "be dead
before dawn."
Arya didn't just evade death in the Battle
of Winterfell.
She lengthed the lives of everyone in the
Seven Kingdoms by killing the Night King.
In the corridors of Winterfell, Melisandre
reminds Arya that she will indeed "shut many
eyes forever … brown, green, and blue eyes,
too," a prophecy as to what Arya is about
to do.
"What do we say to the god of death?"
"Not today."
Moments after the Night King sticks a spear
through Theon's torso and turns his attention
to Bran, Arya suddenly appears behind the
frosty villain.
He attempts to choke her, and her Valyrian
steel dagger falls.
But Arya catches the weapon with her other
hand, finds a space in the Night King's armor,
and stabs him there, causing him and all of
his underlings to shatter into a million tiny
pieces.
The Night King's undoing came around the same
place his "birth" did: in a godswood near
a Heart Tree.
Even more poetically, Bran's life was saved
using the very same dagger that a catspaw
used during an attempt to assassinate him
way back in season one.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.